back in this country as the holiday
season begins there are new concerns
about a possible rail strike after one
of the nation's largest railroad unions
rejected a deal that had been reached
back in September an agreement was
negotiated with the help of the Biden
Administration but that agreement seems
to have fallen apart for now Ed O'Keefe
is at the White House for us Ed Good
morning Tony good morning they are
monitoring this quite closely here at
the White House saying a shutdown is
unacceptable and they're encouraging all
sides to continue talking ahead of a
December 5th deadline 12 rail unions
across the country were asked to ratify
a deal that was reached back in
September but four of the unions have
voted to reject the deal workers would
get a raise under the proposal but the
amount of sick leave continues to be a
major sticking point especially how they
could use their sick leave if they can
all come to an agreement by December 5th
the first of the Unions would walk off
the job and the others are likely to
follow in solidarity and that would cost
a major ripple effect across the economy
just a few weeks before Christmas one
Industry Group estimates a shutdown cost
about two billion dollars a day causing
significant supply chain issues and
delays of food fuel water coal and other
issues that would send prices soaring
now Congress could step in to stop a
rail strike and likely would do so
they've done so in fact 18 other times
in the past here at the White House they
say the president continues to be
briefed on the situation there are no
plans as of now for any Administration
officials here at the White House or
over at the labor department to get
involved but with just under two weeks
to go Nate we'll see if that holds
Ed thank you